hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher when students walk into my
classroom and as I begin an explanation
of a topic often I can see that look in
their eyes where they're just locked
down emotionally they don't want to
engage it seems like something they
can't comprehend and they think it's
impossible for them to ever come to a
point from where they are to be able to
arrive in an understanding where they're
kind of like oh it makes sense I can
actually do these things now and often
that takes you know half an hour or a
week or a month or a year but to get to
there to be able to say I didn't give up
on you know I really do think you can
understand I'm gonna try another way and
then again you can see that change in
their eyes and it's it's an amazing
thing that for me is just what I fell in
love with when I was at school and I got
the opportunity to mentor younger kids
in things like you know how to pitch a
tent or how to you know lead lead a peer
support group and things that they
thought were impossible and I got to not
just help grow their understanding but I
was able to to play a part in them
changing their own concept of who they
were it became a function of their
identity for me that's what teaching is
about that's what that aha moment is
it's not just cool I get Python uses
there now but it's a WoW I am a person
who's capable of understanding that
that's powerful and that's what I love
seeing every day